the Joe Rogan experience I do cuz it's
like a work night for me first we had a
boy up tell people when is it when's the
new season air Friday this Friday
yeah the 17th of January same bat-time
same bat-channel HBO at 10:00 Eastern
and I guess you can figure out the other
time zones from that and we're gonna go
back at it again plenty to talk about
plenty to talk about always see
congratulations by the way on making
this such a big stop in such an iconic
place you did good
thank you thank you I don't know what
the [ __ ] happened stumbled into it will
you do my show sure okay I asked you
before and you were very squirrely about
the people there all talking over each
other
you know I heard you say that one yeah
when you're a to get some guy doing a
terrible impression of me and it's a
very Kyle kolinsky he does a great
impression of you I didn't know who he
was have you ever seen the face off of
Face Swap version that he does of you on
Instagram no oh I don't know find that
before we leave
what's that called I said kolinsky sorry
sorry Kyle no we don't have to look at
this it's amazing to you it was amazing
it wasn't it I don't man people done me
and I can laugh at it something it was
your face he's got your face I was doing
an impression of you you've never seen
it it's not I saw what anyway the point
yeah that doesn't matter the point was
what was the point point was there's not
too many people talking over each other
on your show correct
I feels like it is to me it's very
difficult to have a conversation when
there's so many different people talking
it's such a fundamental criticism of my
show it's not your show is just a format
that's the size but that's of that was I
think you're thinking you're politically
incorrect was that way I'm thinking of
your show right now well I'm there every
week okay and I try I monitor it pretty
closely of course when you have a panel
which we do there can be those moments
but we don't book that kind of person
and that kind of show
it's
not the old let's get them fighting
thing we don't want that and honestly
the number of times when people have
been shouting up for each other and you
can't hear them is very little it's not
even that they're shouting over each
others if you have a point and you want
to talk about something you got to let
it resonate but you would be the
mid-show guest to my left and it would
be a one-on-one you know I do a
one-on-one twice on the show have you
seen the show okay in the middle of the
show yeah I bring out more of a
celebrity usually to my left we toss to
one where's one Harris start going at it
with Ben Affleck because of that Sam was
your one-on-one that's right okay well
that's you know you picked the one
example where somebody that's what you
were talking about I think you've seen
one show Jordan Peterson I only I don't
demand that anyone be a Fett I just like
honesty one of my favorite how we're
getting was he on mr. Hitchens went
after most deaf well he's been dead for
like ten years so what we're
establishing your knowledge of this show
is very limited so I lost a bunch
episode I hope you watch Eddie I don't
need you to have I have lots of fan I'm
not need one more what I'm saying is I'd
like you to do it because I think you'd
be good and I like listening to you and
you'd be to my left one on one there
would be nobody shouting over you
because they wouldn't be involved okay
so you wouldn't have that problem so
will you do it yes great all right and
then we'll walk into a shed
[Applause]